quand vous menez une politique de
sécurité vous luttez il faut avoir une
orientation
aujourd'hui on a le sentiment et c'est
une réalité que monsieur darmana a
réduit la politique de sécurité à la
verbalisation des consommateurs de
produits stupéfiants
si vous voulez démanteler les trafics de
produits stupéfiants qui gangrène notre
pays
comment on fait c'est une politique
coordonnée c'est pas la verbalisation du
consommateur une fois que vous l'avez
verbaliser vous ne mentez pas à
l'origine du trafic
c'est une politique coordonnée avec les
services sociaux la fraude sociale avec
le fisc le blanchiment d'argent
c'est une politique coordonnée qui n'est
pas menée dans notre pays donc
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de volonté pour
lutter contre l'insécurité le
séparatisme jamais aussi fort dans notre
pays on va de recul en recul de
compromis en compromissions et je vous
dire les séparatistes et les
communautarismes très bien duc compris
cela parce qu'ils savent très bien que
le gouvernement est faible et donc leur
idéologie se propage et qui sont les
victimes de cela parce qu'il faut parler
du mans on parle d'islamisme d'islam
radical de salafistes qui sont les
premières victimes
c'est les français de confession
musulmane je vous le dis et donc
aujourd'hui on a laissé s'installer
s'installer ce séparatisme qui se
propage qui gangrène notre pays
mais ça moi je pense que monsieur macro
salle arrange parce qu'il espère une
chose
il a plus de parti il n'a pas de
majorité on voit tous les jours vous
avez d'abord ils perdent les élections à
chaque élection la république en marche
et tous les jours vous avez des membres
de la république en marche qui
démissionne de ce parti est un parti
virtuel et donc monsieur macron qu'est
ce qu'ils espèrent se retrouver face à
marine le pen
les français n'en veulent pas de ce duel
là ne va pas aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui il est important
effectivement d'avoir une fermeté face à
ces compromissions et ce laxisme qu'on a
laissé s'installer dans notre région la
droite les républicains
c'est le premier parti de france nous
sommes les premiers en nombre
d'adhérents en nombre de militants et en
nombre d'élus nous avons gagné toutes
les élections intermédiaires
d'une part et nous avons encore de
gagner les dernières législatives le
parti socialiste n'existe plus hâtive
partiel oui et le le parti socialiste
n'existe plus et la république en marche
et en état de décomposition totale fin
s'il avait existé un jour donc moins
suis favorable à ce que nous ayons des
candidats aient l'air pour mener nos
campagnes et d'ailleurs je vous fais
remarquer et vous avez dû vous en rendre
compte
à chaque fois qu'il ya eu une volonté de
se dissoudre
avec en marche on a perdu donc moi je
considère que vis-à-vis des français
vis-à-vis de nos militants vis-à-vis nos
électeurs il faut de la clarté de la
cohérence et c'est ce que nous faisons
aux républicains la droite on a le
sentiment parfois c'est jamais très bien
ou très bon genre que d'être de droite
moi j'assume d'être de droite je suis
pour l'autorité je suis bourré
respectivement de l'environnement je
suis pour la sécurité je suis pour la
réduction des inégalités inégalités je
suis pour la reconnaissance du mérite et
du travail ce qui n'est plus le cas
aujourd'hui